nome lorenzo giulia cognome o studi
nickname fra i jaill giulia giulia le
tue fuggire ho paura delle api è lui
ragni michael jackson tre aggettivi per
descrivere l'altro rosso viola
kevin spacey allora nei viola è un bel
ragazzo è rihanna quanto ce l'hai lug
181 comunque n'era solo uno erano di più
pensi che fa vj sia un bravo youtuber e
sicuro no si pensi che giulia sia una
brava cantante
si no non so no certo come no no no io
no chi di voi guadagna di più che a
tripoli e cioè il più bello io chi bacia
meglio è kevin spacey milioni di persone
mi hanno visto in un bacio lungo
appassionato nel video pubblicato il
ponte come è stato baciare l'altro stata
una bella esperienza soprattutto dietro
di me
lo farò per sempre
cosa hai pensato quando gabry ponte ci
ha chiamato che figata
ma quando ho saputo pure che c'era
lorenzo ho detto triplamente che figata
tm tocca fa per limone il video del
quale sei più orgoglioso ma
tutti i miei video clip musicali
soprattutto bello dondo quanti sono i
sette nani 7 mai detto come si chiamano
eolo mammolo pisolo cucciolo dotto è il
tuo cantante preferito angelina jolie
oddio io il tuo attore preferito che
christina aguilera in assoluto perché ci
sono cresciuta michael jackson vasca o
doccia e mare è assolutamente mi dici la
capitale della francia a berlino berlino
la capitale della germania e parigi
madrid
ciao voto natia una digital a barcellona
più a capitale della spagna parigi
madrid dalla capitale della russia mi
faceva un po più bravi prova contare
fino a 10 con la numerazione binaria che
fortino facciamo un giochino
quanto fa due più due fa quattro più
quattro calabria 8 più 8 calabro 16 più
sedi ci ha pensato il numero 3 12 5
fatto numero gigi d'alessio vero com'è
possibile non è possibile sta roba
oh mio dio come la tav i canti un pezzo
dell'ultimo singolo di giulia penna
dietro di me perché devo fare ste cose
mai un saluto l'altro ciao altro poi un
saluto chi ti sta guardando ciao a tutti
ragazzi devono morire tutti
massei kevin spacey